il faut dire que la gestion de la
pandémie en suisse a été un peu
différente de ce que vous avez connu en
france il n'y a pas eu de confinement
strict il n'y a pas eu de de couvre feu
le soir
l'économie est resté quand même en
fonctionnement même s'il ya eu quand
même des mesures de restriction
d'activité et dans ce cadre là les
remontées mécaniques ont pu continuer
ont pu ouvrir avec évidemment un certain
nombre de mesures
il y avait des restrictions quant à
l'utilisation des cabines canton nombre
de passagers autorisés par jour et ce et
toute une série de mesures comparables
les sociétés de remontées mécaniques qui
auront dû engager ce qu'on appelait déco
vide angels étaient des personnes qui
étaient là pour s'assurer que dans les
files d'attentes les gens respectent les
distances de sécurité respecte les
gestes barrières et finalement on s'est
aperçu à priori que l'ouverture des
remontées mécaniques n'a pas provoqué a
priori d'explosion du nombre de cas mais
n'a pas non plus l'effet attendu d'un
point de vue économique puisque si les
remontées mécaniques étaient ouvertes
c'était pâle qui a en tout cas dans la
deuxième partie des vacances de noël des
restaurants d'altitude qui était fermée
ce qui implique évidemment une situation
assez compliquée un élément tout simple
bien n'y avait pas de toilettes sur les
domaines skiables ce qui peut freiner
beaucoup de gens pour venir skier en
absence de service mais finalement que
les skieurs très aguerris qui sont venus
et l'offre s'est adressée
essentiellement un public suisse
[Musique]